when shooting a scene there's nothing
more constraining than two people in the
back of a car it's small it's cramped
and everybody faces the same direction
but let's take a look at how despite
these limitations the TV show succession
managed to use creative cinematic
techniques in three scenes where two
characters shiv Roy and Tom wamsgans do
nothing but talk in the back of a car in
the first car scene in season 1 episode
9 Tom and shiv drive to their wedding
venue in rural England the scene begins
with a plain medium shot and the
lighting costume design and color
grading all reminds the viewer that
we're no longer in the busy and colorful
New York City but in the dreary and
overcast UK like the shot the dialogue
starts off innocuous but then shift goes
into what she's really thinking about
and the camera work shifts um hey I
wanted to ask you something uhhuh from
here we go to a close-up on shiv as she
asks Tom for details on the cruise
situation I could do with knowing about
the bad thing in cruises Tom dances
around the issue and shiv continues to
push and the camera work reflects the
new found tension each time shiv asks
Tom a question the camera starts on her
and then pans over to his response this
camera move happens not once not twice
but three times in a row and it gives
shiv all the power while also forcing us
to watch Tom squirm but I did then
destroy all the evidence
so but then finally Tom pushes back and
it becomes a tennis match with the
camera bouncing from shiv to Tom and
back to shiv again that is not even that
bad oh is quite bad it's quite bad from
here we don't return to the medium shot
and instead leave the car entirely
showing the conflict never resolved even
when stuck in a car the camera tells the
story here it shows innocent beginnings
and interrogation and then a standoff
with no resolution and succession isn't
just skilled at dramatic scenes they
also know how to make the back of a car
funny in our second scene in season 2
episode 4 Tom and shiv head to the wayar
royco headquarters in New York City
right from the first shot the scene
feels completely different we return to
that warm busy New York City Hue the
initial medium shot is handheld instead
of fixed and it's more casual we've
dropped the seat belts and the tense
dialogue this initial shot sets the
scene up perfectly for comedy especially
with the wide angle lens stretching Tom
and shiv's features making every hand
gesture and eye movement bigger and when
we go to close-ups the camera moves in
between them and closer to their faces
further exaggerating their movements and
all those differences when combined
completely alter the feeling of these
scenes one dramatic and one comedic you
know church and state and and ACDC and
Ebony and Ivory never the twain shall
meet it's like you and your dad have
finally admitted how much you're into
each other you know now you can you know
not this but now you can bang still in a
car still just talking but a totally
different feeling and that brings us to
perhaps the most famous shot in the
entire show which is you guessed it Tom
and shiv sitting in the back of a car I
won't spoil the ending of the show but
this third car scene takes place at the
end of the series finale as Tom and shiv
drive out of wayar royco forever changed
after Tom enters the car the scene
famously holds on a single medium shot
the frame is almost completely black
visually they could be driving to a
funeral despite holding on just a single
static shot the moment is surprisingly
dynamic as we swirl through the
underbelly of the wayar royco building
we get the famous hand touch in the
middle and then we're forced to do
nothing but look between Tom and shiv
notice how the lights in the basement
alternate between lighting up Tom then
shiv then Tom again and notice the
distance between the two characters in
the frame compared to the other two
scenes these lighting and framing
differences show the profound distance
now between Tom and shiv lit Darkly and
separately framed far apart but still
somehow touching in the middle without
dialogue and without a camera move we
get a story of their tragic Union
succession is a show of mostly people
sitting around talking and yet the
creators still managed to make it tense
funny and heartbreaking now you see
it
[Music]